welcome to this video I'm playing my way
from Norway and what do we go don't want
to play this is scotch against him again
hmm and the key to c3 right to know I
played some gritty wacky line against me
recently here we should be fire fan the
depth of rats a weird line let's just
try to play it as a normal to saw unit
pretend that this Bishop is misplaced
probably it is misplaced maybe maybe
flick this in
doesn't really have a good square I mean
we should be three Bishop before also
isn't very tempting
yep took him a while and it's not a good
line I mean this is a known position
without age six and age 6 n should
really hurt me next move is d5 yeah this
is really really really awkward because
ed 595 and I'm threatening a 5pm
threatening a five and then deform
yeah it's awkward for what really is
yeah Bishop g5 is a weird move maybe it
is directed against black pre moving you
have any a six or whatever so we are
well here i will take I guess right c6
probably yeah I think I'm going back
this is pin is something that should
annoy white somewhat
ok so now i can take the damages pawn
structure but i don't know move like
Bishop c5 looks dangerous but i still
think it's it's ok i have ninety-seven
do i want to go back there i can go 97
anyway now I'm going back here it's ok I
mean Bishop c5 i can even contemplate
just a 5 me5 and we should be six ok I
think I'm just cancel ok castling you
might take age 6
let's try let's win that win that tempo
always have to be cautious a little bit
against me is a very good technical
player might come up with something
crazy that all that does work
okay so hmm I could go for a queen trade
now with 95 maybe the Queen trait was ok
doesn't do that that surprises me
thinking Bishop c5 would be would be
coming ok so yeah I can know if I take
this Bishop c6 just just be come on
let's let's let's get out of this that
doesn't look too bad anyway now Bishop
h6 really should work ok here
squeem e5 and more voice is just showing
off now I don't know I don't know let's
connect rooks so what now it's at looks
fine a king doesn't really have great
squares to go to ok c 5s kind of not
protected so if i move this night 93
maybe and yeah that that that should win
some material
yeah that wind stuff not quite clear
what it wins but it does win some stuff
like resins okay so I'm Frank your
opening yeah sure chief I've okay yeah i
was thinking and by the way maybe see
three years old but it's not not clear
that when the Queen c7 does happen in
the in the smooth mora sometimes so it's
probably not terrible here when a 69 th
26 year and now maybe Bishop h4 i mean
this is this is leading to a long line
that is known to be good for black
really not sure what is relatively best
the engine wants to go nighty too now
maybe I think that might be better than
the game I mean here we are really
talking about serious problems okay if
I've is already a bit desperate here it
seems that he could have taken and gone
Bishop f4 and it's at all so I should
avoid knight c6 but you didn't do that
you can do it again ya bish ampere
that's 97 I thought and there should be
ok c4 cakes
yeah probably here I mean I didn't
really pay much attention to that but
maybe he really should take this to at
least level the material in some cases
with Queen d6 it's difficult for black
to avoid the Queen trade and if Queens
get traded this is probably giving wide
very good drawing chances I know that
thing this is to check this is just
winning in various ways yeah iam stuff
gets gets lost this is the check
harshest one checkmate with a with a
mate and I'm threatening this this 1d
four kinds of things okay well thanks
for watching